une dernière levée monique les banques
bonjour bonjour vous êtes vraiment un
enfant de michel barrette et de jean
marc parent dans votre façon de raconter
mais le truc c'est de leur donner
en fait ce qu'il nos styles se
ressentent beaucoup
michelle et moi on voit on va puiser
dans notre quotidien brute crédit du
matériel moi je vois partir d'une fin de
semaine c'est soit que je reviens avec
un nouveau numéro le exactement un beau
spectacle
puis on aime les gens et que je vois pas
de noms mais je n'en mange ma force pour
pour jaser avec les jets qu'à mon
spectacle est fini les mettons que je
suis parfait le banc d'humoristes je
veux mais tu roules j'ai déjà été
rappelé au métro puis j'ai déjà placé
des disques a nagé en amont puis j'ai
déjà fait des ménages pgd jeu était beau
ce vote pour moi je me colle
vous allez manger jeu certains de vos
admirateurs et admiratrices
je peux maintenant dire qu'il n'ya pas
plus d'un mois - de me hanter les
marchés avec une salade césar cherche
une dame deans a tout bonnement pays
elle gardait ses petits enfants
ça m'a donné le sens son petit-fils à
difficile à tenir le temps que je ferais
pas la salade ou objets les petits sur
moi puis je lis tintin par spielberg est
sûre tout d'abord c'est de toute
évidence lui venant manger mais oui je
te l'image et jeudi enfin barbe qui on
allait manger de la baguette chez
monsieur à joliette qui nous a tout
bonnement éviter après un spectacle
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de versement
devrait puis métier j'ai toujours géré
jose a pris j'aurais pas seul mais mes
techniciens sont assez costaud que la
demande toujours si vous tombez
technicien fort ok on y voit de 500 voix
de foudre les gens vous mettez à swatch
une lasagne tête à côté de 6
pentax cassante avait un trou dans le
spectacle comment fais tu pour vous
renouveler parce que les anecdotes on en
a un certain nombre mais randonnée la
banque s'épousent non oui tu te fais
mais j'en parle dans mon troisième
spectacle jeudi qu' un moment donné de
ma vie où c'était complètement fou je
faisais de la radio le matin je faisais
de la télé dans le jour je faisais ont
animé les quatre cents coups et de
refuser à lui moins chez the price is
right je les fais des spectacles le soir
mais la radio macquet peut accueillir
beaucoup de monde un peu me prenait
énormément de mon temps puis je t'aime
je te fatigues et puis je me souviens
dans les dernières années que j'ai fait
cette vie de flux endormez des trois
cadres heures par jour deux parties et
je me suis de partir le matin chez moi
sainte-adèle de vouloir la radio pour me
dire mais qu'est ce que je vous raconte
et d'espérer que quelqu'un fasse suppose
ou qu'une femme soit en panne pour
l'aider pour avoir quelque chose à
raconter
il ya toujours quelque chose qu'elle
veut toujours de tiges mais m moi je
devais en mettant sur papineau le japon
2-1 et simplement de mettre du gaz mais
si je voyais des trois autos stationnées
vous voyez une femme qui est en train de
s'engueuler quelqu'un je me stationner
jobard qui est son problème puisque les
rangs 30 b déjà mais je cours après les
anecdotes que j'en parle dans mon
spectacle
pire vous l'avez pas aborder 2010 à 2015
ça a été des années folles pour vous
beaucoup de télévision cinq ans de radio
mais ce que ce trou à l'époque non parce
que j'avais atteint 30 ans j'avais 28 29
30 ans j'étais partout mais aujourd'hui
ce qui me fait me demander leurs frais
dessus parce qu'elle était il ya pas
deux fois par année je te dirai aussi
moi je reçois un appel de réduire à
montréal pour me demander si je revenais
qu'on m'offre veux tu vas aller retour
va faire le show du matin se doit de
faire un show des mid et le avec un
enfant de sept mois la maison j'aime ma
vie je me remets levé avec mon garçon je
me surprends du temps pour ma copine et
moi je me sois les majors et steria moi
j'ai commencé en faisant les premiers
passages où josé je regardais louis josé
houde et je me dis un jour c'est ce que
je fais je voudrais seulement fait des
spectacles loches me ou ce que je
voulais qu'il n'allait pas que c'est
impossible pour moi d'avoir une relation
stable qui soit et à drummondville
l'autre soir tête à laval l'autre soit
et à québec
j'étais jamais l'autre il a au contraire
ça ça m'était jamais arrivé j'ai hâte de
vous
la maison j'avais pu j'aurais voulu
avoir des enfants plus tôt mettez le dis
au fait en sorte que c'était pas
possible à cause de mon auraient deux
fois en fait tout est possible mais je
voulais être présents puis l'a40 en
avoir un enfant le meuble on trouve que
ça va tellement bien qu'elle parle déjà
d'un deuxième place qu'un bon manga dont
un code et tout le monde dit la même
chose le lieu du concert rock and roll
mais dans deux ans tu vas t'ennuyer mais
tu ferais mieux de le faire et là parce
que déjà d'un coup je touche comme en
bois qu'est ce qu'on fait la conscience
de ça mais oui je 13e rue puis ce qu'on
entendait tout ce que fut fondée par
keller c'est beaucoup merci infiniment
bon ça y est